限定の人間の人間のことだけ考えると
もういつでも何か意見
立場 見解があって行動するんです
その見解っていうのはほとんど仏教では間違っていると思ってるんですね
全て 例えばある人を見て気に入っちゃう
その場合もなぜ気に入ったんですか？というと
やっぱり真面目からの心に見解があったんです
こういうこういう形はいいんだと
好きだと そこで見た人はその形に当てはめちゃったんだから
その人のことを気に入ってしまっちゃうんです
それただの見解のせいなんです
子供の時はおもちゃ見るともう我を忘れるほど頭真っ白くなっちゃうんですね
もうちょっと大きくなるとすごくそれも嫌ですよと
小さい時は子供を喜ばせたい場合はおもちゃなんかあげればいいんです
すごく喜んで大好きですよと言ってくれる
もうちょっと 5  6年大きくなったらまたおもちゃあげてみてください
ものすごく嫌われちゃうんです
そこで何ですか？というと
その見解なんですね おもちゃは世界一番いいものだと
その時はその見解で終わっちゃうし
大きくなったところで違う見解があって
違うものが一番いいですよと思っちゃうし
若くなっちゃったらまた違う見解で違うものが一番好きですよと言っちゃうし
少年になって老年になるとまた違う見解なんですね
だから一体全体何が一番好きですか？と人に聞いたってわかるわけじゃないし
人はその時の見解によっていい加減なんですね
本人はいい加減じゃないんだけど
もっと高いレベルから見ると結局いい加減なんですね
お腹がものすごく空いていると
もうご飯はすごく美味しく感じちゃうし
ご飯食べているならばもう別に見ても面白くも何ともないし
だから美味しいという感じが
欲がその時の見解によって生まれるもので
見解もぐるぐると変わっちゃいますけど
人はそれを気にしない
人その見解の代わりに新しい見解を作る
そこで全ての人々はものは存在しているんだ
ものはいいものだ 生きていることはいいものだとかね
私はいるんだと 私に魂があるんだというふうな基本的な見解で全てやっているんです
それ誰一人も治ったわけじゃないんです
我々にはものは正しく見えないというふうに出来上がってるんだから
ですから 全ての生命は見解を持っている
その見解も残念ながら正しくはありません
その見解に基づいているんだから
まあ楽しくなっちゃうし
そんなにも面白くないものだって
そんなにもいいものでない場合は
別にまあ普通な状態になっちゃうし
それで心は 4つに分けられるんですね
見解ある心と見解ない心
まあまあまあ そこら辺それぐらいでいいと思いますけど
見解なくても楽しいものは楽しいんですね
例えば食べ物は何でもいいと
それも見解ですけど まああるいはこういうこと
例えば人はなんとなく口を開けてるんだと
そこで虫でもいいんだけど
飛んで口の中に入っちゃったと
虫は置いといて 誰かがサッと口の中に飴一つ入れたんだと
別に食べたいという気持ちやったわけでもないし
ただ口を開けてただけで
そこで人が飴一つ一旦一つ入れたところで
味がもう必然的に感じちゃうでしょ
その場合はまあ別に 人間にとっては飴だから気持ちのいい味なんですね
その時は気持ちよくなっちゃうんですね
でもわざわざ見解やったわけじゃないんです
まあ仏教では分かりやすく言えば
ただ仏教の人々はきちんと瞑想して
無常も結構理解して 輪廻のことも理解して
なんとか悟ろうと努力していて
世の中については何かほとんど未練がなくてという信仰深い人々いるんです
そういう人々でも 食べる時はわざわざと美味しいものを捨てて
全く美味しいものを選んで食べようということはしない
食べる場合は美味しいものを選んで食べる
自分の家族とは楽しく生活をする
ちゃんと仕事をする もう金儲けもする
だから出て そのために必死になって仕事をすることこそ人間の人生やとか
そうは思わない 子供のために死んでもいいんですよと
そこまではない 子供がじゃあ育ててあげようと
育ててあげる時は子供と一緒に生活すると楽しい
それは楽しいと どうせ食べなくちゃいけないんだから
じゃあ仕事でもしましょうと
それでもうちゃんともらったお金はちゃんと守っておきましょうと
誰が持っていってもいいんですよと
私は欲のない人だから
もう金は誰でも持っていけと
そんなことじゃ困りますよ
お金もちゃんと政府に入れて鍵をかけておく
でも他の普通の人よりはものすごい欲とかない
結局全部いつか捨ててきますよという風な生き方をしているんです
いわゆる仏教徒の生き方と仏教徒でないない人の生き方というのは全く変わりはない
同じ生き方なんですが
ただ一人にはすごい見解がある
もう一人にはそんなような見解がない
そこで見解っていうのは
この無常ということを知らないということなんです
そういうふうに理解してもわかりやすいと思います
それだけで心はつになります
次に心がまたそのつを 2つに分けます
それはササンカーラ アサンカーラという言葉でそれで割りますよ
それはアビダンマでも本当は説明ないんです
なんでササンカーラ アサンカーラですか
角度 あの 4つの心はササンカーラ心とアサンカーラ心と 2つに分ける
ササンカーラ アサン アサンカーラ
ササンカーラ この場合
僕が問題にするのは ここでこのサンカーラ
サっていうのはある アっていうのはない
ない ある 両方入ってますから
ない こちらはあるだけで
サンカーラがある サンカーラがあることではないと
ない ないと アサンカーラ
サっていうのは英語では with という
with サンカーラ この場合は without サンカーラ
英語の言葉だったらぴったしなんですね
with  without いれば同じこと
サンカーラって何ですか？ サンカーラっていうのはもうちょっとこのエネルギーを固まって
もうなんとかちょっと努力して
いわゆるいきなり突然行動ではなくて
行動しなくちゃという
なんとなく  のんびりというか
もう励ましてもらって
じゃあじゃあやりますと
という風な感じの心なんですね
心にその 2種類あるんです
この説明してしてしてして
それでもわからなくて
それでもわからなくても
あーやっとやっと徐々に徐々にじわじわわかってきましたという人もいて
さっとわかったという人もいるんですね
その性格みたいなものに
それはずっと引き継いじゃうんです
理解の場合も 見てすぐ理解する人と
じーっと観察しないと理解しない人もいるんですね
普通の行動でいえば じゃあどこか行こうかと言ったら
じゃあ行きましょうという感じじゃなくて
じゃあどこ行くんでしょうかね
そこへ何があるんでしょうかね
じゃあでもちょっと何かこれも仕事もあるんだけど
まあじゃあいいわ 行きましょうと
そんな感じで行動になる場合は何ですか？頑張って頑張ってやっと行動だからササンカーラ
サンカーラというのはそういう努力みたいなものなんですね
日本語で何でしたっけ
あ 行 有行 このサンカーラ
行と書いてるんです 行くという感じ
行 ですからこの場合は有行
この場合は無行でしょう
サンカーラはある場合は有行で
サンカーラはない場合は無行で
行があるかないか これすごいこの微妙な差なんです
ただの微妙な差で それほどカルマ的には影響はないんです
でも修行についてはちょっとした気になるところはあるんです
特に指導者なんかは なんで同じ指導しているのにあなたは遅いかと
なんであの人は早いんですかという問題なんですね
すぐわかる人もいて もう無常見えて見えて見えて見えて
もう呆れてる 呆れるほど見えてるんだけど
まだまだ心はもうサティの境地に行かないという
そんな人はいるんですね
その心のなんとなくちょっとした性質なんですね
ですから それを何とかして
素早く心動くように 鋭く
すぐ瞬間に心が動くようにしておいた方が
まあなんとかいうと便利なんですね
教える側にしたって あまり説明しなくてもわかってくれると
もうそれほどありがたいことはないんです
その 2つに分けて 欲の心は 8種類にします
ですから こういうことで
喜があります 喜びがありまして
見がありまして 有行の心と喜びがあって
見がありまして 無行の心と
それから喜びがありまして
見がなくて 有行の心と無行の心と
それから不苦不楽で見がある有行の心と無行の心と
それから不苦不楽の感覚で見がない有行の心と無行の心と
その 8つの切り取りにすべての欲の心は分けているんです
まとめているんです いっぱいあるかもしれませんだけど
その 8つで十分と思っているんですね
ということは 例えば 1万円見てみたら欲が生まれると
その欲は見る人によって違うんですね
例えば 1,000円お小遣いもらう子供にとっては
1万円見ちゃったらもう飛び上がるほどの喜びが感じちゃうし
で 普通の人だったらまた違う喜びを感じちゃうし
まあお金はあまり困るほどある人にとってはもう悪くはない感じが生まれるんだけど
そんなに喜びはない ですから欲は欲ですけど
いろんな差があるんですね
ですから そこまで心を分析しちゃうともうやりきれませんだからね
ですから そういう大雑把な 8種類に分けてます
他の 4つには時間ないんですが
どうもありがとうございます
次に  ありがとうございます